foreign
[Music]
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
today I want to take you through an
exercise that helped out one of my
students in getting down her split Time
same direction movements in wall plane
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so most of us when we first learn how to
do split Time same direction at the
beginning of our flow Journey we're
learning it in a wheel playing place
that is we are learning it in this
position where the two POI are spinning
at our sides like Wagon Wheels and it's
not hard to see why if we try to do this
from a wall plane place that is a place
where both of the POI are on the same
side of our body like a wall in front of
us nine times out of ten we're going to
find ourselves in a position where
they're starting to run into each other
or one of our body parts it takes
learning some additional stuff including
a skill that I refer to as the lanes of
poi in order to make this stable now I
had a a student this past week who was
really really struggling with this and I
came up with an exercise for her that I
think might be useful for many of you
all out there as well now if all of this
is sounding like Greek to you don't
worry I have plenty of tutorials both on
timing and direction as well as the
lanes of poi that I will go ahead and
link to down in the description as well
as up in the cards but if these things
are sounding familiar and like something
that you are wrestling with too let me
show you some answers as to how to get
there so here's how this works when
we're First Learning split Time same
direction we're usually kind of counting
it off in our heads like a one two one
two kind of pace and then bringing it
into wall plane we have to keep up that
same Pace well at the same time keeping
the Poise planes clear of each other
it's a lot to think about right but what
if I told you there was a way that you
could take some of that Knowledge from
your split Time same direction spinning
in wheel plane and apply it to your wall
plane position too so to start off here
we're going to need to talk a little bit
about what I like to call the lanes of
poi that is when we're spinning in wheel
plane here we have our POI separated to
either side of our body there is at
least a shoulder's width between them so
they're not likely to tangle into each
other whereas when we switch into
spinning them in wall plane here the
only way that we can do this is if we
physically keep some distance between
these planes with our arms so rather
than having our hands out an even
distance from the front of our body like
we normally might we need to begin
training ourselves to keep one hand
further out and one hand further back
that way when our audience sees this
from the front we can keep the plane
separate and as far as the audience is
concerned there's really not that big a
difference so we're going to need to
drill two positions to start to get this
down the first one is going to involve
us turning to our left and bend your
elbows at a 90 degree angle so your
hands are sticking straight out in front
of you now I want you to take your left
arm and move it slightly forward so that
your elbow is clearing your shoulder now
you're going to take your left arm and
move it slightly backwards so that the
elbow is just slightly behind your
shoulder this should create a position
where your left hand is just a few
inches in front of your right but when
viewed from the front it looks as though
they're basically at the same distance
by the same token we also want to try
turning to our right and again we're
going to bend our elbows at a right hand
angle and I'm going to stick my right
arm just slightly forward so that the
elbow clears the shoulder and my left
arm is going to go slightly back so that
my elbow is just behind my shoulder once
again I'm in a position where I have one
hand this time my right several inches
in front of my left and when I turn to
face the audience they look more or less
like they're at the same depth so what
does this do for us it creates positions
in which we can have the two POI
spinning in the same plane but because
they have a couple inches between those
planes they're not likely to run into
each other whether it happens to be over
at your right side or it happens to be
over at your left side okay so how do we
make this work with what we know in
wheel plane first and foremost I want
you to go ahead and shorten up the POI
so that they're about elbow length you
can do this by wrapping the POI around
your hands or just gripping the tethers
a little bit further up either way
though I want you to get that split time
feeling going in wheel plane here to
start with now I want you to go ahead
and practice having your right hand
cross back and forth across you as you
keep the left hand spinning on your left
hand side
as you're doing this I want you to pause
your right hand over at your left hand
side here now for all intents and
purposes you're still in this wheel
plane place but you've now Frozen your
right hand over where it's going to be
if it were to be and while playing and
once you just know it if you want to
then you can then turn your entire body
to face the POI and
you're now spinning in Split Time same
direction in wall plane cool and by the
same token we can start Crossing that
left hand POI back and forth back and
forth back and forth as the right hand
is just hovering over on the right hand
side and stop it over on the right hand
side here as though almost it we're
spinning in Buzz saw plane try and keep
the two going in Split Time same
direction and then turn your entire body
to face your right hand POI and look at
that you know how split Time same
direction working with your right hand
forward so I want you to practice going
back and forth like this and really
build this up step by step first think
that you're going to try and work to do
10 beats back and forth with this right
hand before you make the right hand POI
stop over at the left hand side here and
again try and keep this stable with the
right hand POI basically in a buzz slot
plane and the left hand POI going out in
wheel plane still for 10 beats in itself
when both of these feel comfortable then
it's time to work on turning your entire
body over to putting these POI in wall
plane so I hope this exercise worked for
you if it did please post a video of
yourself doing it to Instagram or Tick
Tock and tag me in it I would love to
see your hard work if you got anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these lovely people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very very generous support and if you
out there watching are not currently a
supporter but would like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get early access to all of my
content a whole host of other awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you'd like to check out
some of my other beginner POI lessons I
will include a link to a playlist of
them down in the description as well as
up here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon
peace